louvoyer entre les îles du golfe du
morbihan est un privilège qui se mérite
seuls les marins aguerris peuvent se
risquer dans ce labyrinthe mouvementée
il faut en effet une solide connaissance
de la topographie sous marine pour se
frayer une route à travers cette large
baie qui voit défiler les courants les
plus puissants d'europe
[Musique]
ronan le borgne a tout quitté pour
devenir un jour capitaine de navire
il rêve de prendre la barre de l'un de
ces petits ferry qui font la liaison
entre les nombreuses îles du golfe
va réagir et
trop bien
ronan navigue ici depuis qu'il est
enfant mais ils comptent aujourd'hui sur
son ami thierry calage pour lui livrer
certains secrets de cette petite mer
intérieure
la sensation que donner des fois le
courant là c'est créer cette scène
paysage qui bouge
que les balises avance que ce qu'on
arrive à faire croire aux touristes des
fois
il ya des endroits où on sait que
même avec nos bateaux à passagers moteur
à fond si on est mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment et ben au recul
les deux hommes se sont lancé un défi il
souhaite franchir un des passages
délicats du golfe le célèbre courants
dits de la jument un tapis roulant
liquide qui peut atteindre 20 km heure
lorsque la jument se faufile entre deux
îles elle gagne alors en puissance
pour votre très bien la différence d'une
courant qui monte du contrecoup rang
juste derrière on voit la ligne
[Musique]
voilà le courant de logements
faudrait pas que le vent tombe
ça continue
on va être forte
à peine entré dans les remous le petit
voilier devient ta gouvernable il manque
même de faire un tour sur lui même
[Musique]
le contre-courant qui m'a qui m'a pris
d'un seul coup et il a pris le nez du
bateau alors que le plus était en virée
à
365 est rigolo même avec un petit bateau
comme ça on peut être pris entre deux
feux carrément quoi
[Musique]
malgré leurs frêles embarcations nos
navigateurs ne sont pas peu fiers
d'avoir vaincu les tourbillons du grand
courant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tel un flux sanguin le courant de la
jument irrigue le golfe et ses marais
depuis des millénaires à une époque
glaciaire où le niveau de la mer se
trouvait 120 mètres en dessous de son
niveau actuel
il y a vingt mille ans les hommes du
néolithique et riches d'ici plusieurs
monuments encore visibles aujourd'hui
monticule de pierres et de terre le
tumulus de l'île de gavrinis est une
ancienne sépulture
et puis sur une petite île juste en face
se dresse un alignement de menhirs
ces mégalithes sont vraisemblablement
les vestiges d'anciennes croyances
[Musique]
interdit d'accès l'îlot d'hernani qui
accueille exceptionnellement ce mois
d'octobre une équipe de scientifiques
des universités de rennes et de vannes
ils sont venus réaliser toute une série
de mesures et prendre des photos
aériennes afin de mieux documenter ce
décor mystérieux
ce que tu pense qu'on peut aller
survoler la deuxième enceinte qui est
sur l'autre branche là
là on a la première enceinte de
mégalithes qui se poursuit sur l'estran
et on a carrément la deuxième enceinte
de mégalithes qui est totalement immergé
l'a donc là si vous voulez en direct on
a un témoin des fluctuations du niveau
de la mer
au niveau du sud de la bretagne la ligne
de rivage et décalé de 70 km plus au sud
vous imaginez donc au niveau des
paysages des paysages de step de toundra
faut imaginer des mammouths des reines
qui piétine et le sol morbihannais est
donc au cours de la déglaciation on
assiste à une remontée du niveau marin
donc au comblement petit à petit de ses
valets là où passent et les fleuves qui
deviennent petit à petit des chenaux
sous marin
lors de la fonte des glaces et de la
montée des océans les parties les plus
élevés du golfe subsiste sous forme d'
île où d'îlots
les courants de marée empreinte le lit
des rivières et creuse de larges vallées
sous marine plus ou moins profondes
c'est un paysage caché que seule une
poignée de téméraires peuvent explorer
sous le regard attentif de joël gernier
un moniteur de plongée très expérimenté
bon donc bien comprendre comment
fonctionnent les flux marin
alors donc la mise à l'eau va se faire
de ce côté ci et on a toute cette masse
d'eau qui va passer deux fois par jour à
l'aller ou au retour par des petits
passages très profond et qui va donner
une grande accélération au courant nous
on est ici on va passer par cette petite
voiture et avoir le coup de pied aux
fesses gentiment on en a un autre qui
passent ici mais là il ya de quoi déjà
s'amuser donc se laisser porter si vous
voulez donner même un petit peu
l'accélération mouvement vous pouvez
plier les jambes pour les scellés les
palmes se fait reprendre par la force du
courant on a 60 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau qui passe par heure sur des forts
coefficients de marée c'est énorme donc
comme il ya toutes les îles et donc des
toitures ou le court on veut passer à
l'intérieur et en même temps en fonction
des vallées va générer des tourbillons
aussi et des courants linéaire ou non
la plongée dérivantes est un sport
extrême qui nécessite une préparation
sans faille
il est 10 heures du matin la mer descend
depuis trois heures le courant est de
plus en plus fort
[Musique]
surtout fait attention c'est qu'on
arrive pas c'est un caillou en général
le réflexe on a tendance à appuyer avec
les mains sur ce que là tu appuies sur
la main si tu vas me couler et dans ces
cas là j'ai tendance à moi vous tapez le
caillou ah bon c'est pas cool pour moi
mais inclinaison n'est pas le petit coup
de rein et hop ça passe
une bouée sera le seul repère qui en
surface permettra de suivre la palanquée
pendant toute la durée de la dérive
en quelques secondes à peine le groupe
se retrouve propulsé par une force
invisible
ils deviennent alors le jouet des
éléments mais tente néanmoins de ne pas
heurter les amas de roches qui se
trouvent sur leur passage
[Musique]
ils sont là les bulles sont là bas là on
se trouve en plein dans la troisième
heure de marée ça veut dire que c'est là
où on a le courant le plus fort ça c'est
le signe courant en plongée et là ça
envoie
ses des sensations pour aller voler soul
et par ce fait je trouve propulsé dans
le courant un petit peu comme un
parachute eskers dans l'air et qui va
essayer de se stabiliser et de se tenir
et se laisser emporter pas sur une
verticalité mais sur un côté ou
horizontale
[Musique]
dans la barre
bronzé
l'extra les sensations de gaulle et
ouais ça on voit quelqu'un qui sait tout
avant latéral vrille
les rochers qui sont passés super crains
c'est que ça arrive à une vitesse du
coup on était un peu surpris que c'est
ça qui est c'est fou
le courant dans mis de côté par timo
boll de l'école du pont n'est plus dans
la même veine d'eau moyenne vitesse
supérieure donc forcément j'accélère tu
dois partir à ce moment là alors que les
plongeurs se remettent de leur aventure
mémorable dans les profondeurs du golfe
un peu plus loin sur l'île d'ars
[Musique]
un homme s'apprête à remettre en marche
un vieux moulin à marée
jean bulot art construit de ses propres
mains ce vestiges datant du xvième
siècle
[Musique]
il est 13h30 la mère a presque atteint
son niveau le plus bas
c'est un véritable tableau de maître qui
apparaît alors
un peu partout dans les zones les moins
profondes de cette mer intérieure
les ostréiculteurs sont au travail les
pieds dans l'eau
la marée basse et propice au
retournement des poches d'huîtres l'un
des trésors du golfe du morbihan
elle puise tout leurs nutriments dans
les masses d'eaux chargées de plancton
qui circulent entre les îles
malgré tout les cartes marines que l'on
peut trouver à bord d'un bateau dans le
golfe si l'on veut éviter les pièges de
la jument il faut se fier à son
expérience et surtout à ses yeux
avant de pouvoir décrocher son diplôme
de capitaine de ferries ronan le borgne
doit apprendre les subtilités de la
navigation automobile puis tu vas te il
est guidé par son ami et associé
françois pérusse qui connaît ce dédale
comme sa poche
on est en train d'éviter le fort courant
pour attraper le contre courant là on va
passer le
moment le faucheur
essaye de prendre de la vitesse dans le
contre et tours pour avoir un bon élan
pour pouvoir passer le
courant et si j'ai bien compris des
histoires font que j'essaie de mettre
mon bateau déjà face au courant avant de
l'attaquer comme avant de rentrer dedans
sinon le nez il se fait embarquer je
pars je ressors des gaules faut fermer
l'angle que fait la queue du bateau avec
la queue du courant voilà là il faut le
mettre quasiment face au courant sinon
ça va pas bien se passer
[Musique]
voilà le sens dans la barre
la lgv atos met bien secoué dans les
marmites les marmites sont des remontées
d'eau en fait c'est un peu le contraire
du tourbillon la flotte est projeté au
conglomérat en s'armant que se déploie
et ça ça donne des secousses au bateau
tu as des décalages latéraux comme ça
qui peuvent aller jusqu'à un mètre assez
brutalement d'ailleurs
[Musique]
pourtant d'avoir un regard neuf
par ailleurs garde les remplaçants
prendre une belle
[Musique]
j'essaie de ne pas me laisser embarquer
deux
de garder ça il ya des moments où ça me
fait bouger le cul du bateau donc
j'essaie de garder le contrôle c'est une
sensation hyper agréable de dérapage le
deux
mâts de glisse allez y encore un trou
devant le
peuple c'est pas de la houle c'est c'est
une bosse
le château et de vente
pour quelqu'un qui débute c'est bien
d'emprunter ces passages la marée basse
comme ça on va les caillasses pascal
c'est à marée haute que celle plus
dangereux parce qu'on les voit pas dans
le golfe les quasiment tous les navires
à passagers navigant visuel chacun a ses
petits ces petits alignement en tête ces
petits repères voilà le le piège d'un
jeune marin faut rester humble en fait
on même tabarly se faisait avoir il a
mis un jour son pen duick 1 sur la truie
d'arradon voit là bas pour retenir ça en
tête même les meilleurs se font à voir
donc si on est moins meilleur que les
meilleurs on est censé se faire avoir un
jour donc faut rester humble ans
si tout va bien et si la jument est
clémente ronan et françois devrait
atteindre l'île aux moines d'ici une
vingtaine de minutes
il est 16h le courant de la jument
envahit peu à peu les parties les plus
reculés du golfe du morbihan
[Musique]
l'ags une vasière marais et îlots sont à
nouveau noyée sous les eaux venue du
large
[Musique]
avec la marée montante le vent s'est
levé mais jules compte bien aller voir
ce qui se passe à la sortie du golfe
côté mer là où le courant de la jument
prend son élan entre port navalo et
locmariaquer
quand je suis arrivé la première fois je
pense est arrivé bêtement dans un grand
lac et le premier jour où j'ai rencontré
le golfe on me l'a présenté je me suis
rendu compte que c'était pas un lac
c'est une rivière qui changent de sens
pour tenter 6h elle change d'intensité
avec les différentes marées avec le vent
j'adore naviguer ici s'échangeant sait
jamais la même chose on tourne pas la
même mère et à le courant qui est là qui
est présent et ça c'est de la magie quoi
moi c'est ça que j'adore ici ce côté
puissant mais en même temps coule et sa
porte bien son nom morbihan la petite
mer bah c'est vraiment ce qu'on retrouve
là tous les effets de la mer à une
échelle un peu un peu réduite mais super
agréable et c'est un terrain de jeu
magnifique pour le peillac
guide pour les kayakistes jules défis
parfois les éléments qui se déchaînent
dans le goulet et 3 qui mène à l'océan
écoutez là ça fait du bruit on entend
vraiment les vagues elle commence à
déferler c'est pas des grosses vagues
mais ça va quand même de jouer il vous
plait
savoir être est ce là où ça vient rigolo
[Musique]
on est petit quoi n'est pas grand chose
on joue pas contre la nature là nous
accepte un peu mais c'est vraiment la
nature la plus forte ça restera la mer
il ya des fois
on y va on a envie de gagner mais on
assure maintenant la safa cependant ça
va pas été suffisant le but plaisir
retour dans le golfe où les tourbillons
les marmites et le clapot provoquée par
la jument se calme peu à peu avec la fin
de la marée montante
pour jules mais aussi pour tous ceux qui
composent avec les éléments le golf est
un univers à part un lieu unique qui
rassemble les amoureux de la mer et les
marins de tous horizons
ben tiens j'ai l'impression d'apercevoir
au nom elle son bateau
[Musique]
saga
on a été joué à l'extérieur ça a bougé
un peu à trouver un peu de merde de
coust écoulée puis là on est venu au
calme dans les courants
[Musique]
pas trop mais je suis content d'être
chez moi j'étais
contemplatif et plus ça va plus
j'aime bien pourtant je le connais
depuis tout petit selon le maire
j'ai juste l'impression d'être à ma
place ici
ne pas avoir envie d'être ailleurs
c'est ce que je pourrais dire en résumé
après des heures de navigation dans les
puissants courants du golfe après nous
avoir livré certains secrets de cette
baie singulière il est temps pour renan
le borgne de retrouver la terre ferme et
les rivages de son île préférée l'île de
berder
et sa vue imprenable sur la jument
il est 20 heures la mer est presque
plein
[Musique]
ce soir ça on réentend le voyou courant
quand tous les bateaux sont rentrés que
les moteurs sont l'étincelle axa
rien un bon sentiment en fin de journée
là c'est quand ça se calme c'est
hyper agréable
c'est le plus bel endroit du monde
c'est pas pour rien que les hommes
préhistoriques ils avaient fait leur
tumulus sur la pointe sud là ils
prenaient pas les pierres aux endroits
[Musique]